mindy grossman has spent her
professional life thinking about what we
want to buy
and how we want to feel from fashion
with tommy hilfiger and ralph lauren
to nike with phil knight and the home
shopping network with barry diller
she's worked alongside some of the most
innovative and iconoclastic
entrepreneurs of our time
constantly pushing herself just beyond
what was comfortable
i don't believe i've truly been 100
ready for any job i've ever taken
now she's got arguably her biggest job
and the biggest challenge of her career
weight watchers which grossman has
rebranded ww
is more than a company it's a way of
life a state of mind
and maybe exactly the sort of tricky
messy human-focused endeavor
she's been preparing for all along
adding to those challenges
in the past year she's faced a global
pandemic and some harsh criticism over
some of her decisions
i spoke with mindy to find out what a
career squarely focused on bringing your
true
feelings and experiences can tell us
about the changing role of the modern
leader
i think too many women have felt that
they don't put themselves
out there because they have to wait to
be perfect
[Music]
first of all i'm so grateful to you for
doing this
and opening up your home virtually
to me originally you set out to be a
lawyer
or that's what you thought you were
going to do true absolutely
from the time i was a little girl
watching perry mason with my grandmother
i was convinced that i wanted to be a
lawyer and actually
ultimately a judge
you know i'm an adopted child and when i
was
about four or five i had to go into the
court
and there was a judge it actually
happened to be
a female judge which was unusual at that
time and i remember going up to her
and you know she affirmed that i was
going to be with
my parents and i said i want to be
someone that can have that kind of
impact on
people and that was going to be my
approach
and you know i was an english literature
and philosophy major
planning to go to law school in the fall
of 78 but i made the pretty radical
decision
and remember calling my parents and i
said
i've decided not to go to law school and
i'm leaving right now and i'm moving to
new york
and i think that moment was
defining because i realized
for a fact that not having taken that
risk
would actually have been riskier than
taking the risk
and redefining my path and so
you end up not a lawyer you end up in
the menswear business for quite some
time like that's where you
where you start out it was that
purposeful or was that just the job that
was available because
you you make your way through that leg
of the business
pretty dramatically and pretty quickly
you know when i first moved to new york
i had an interview at a big multi-brand
menswear conglomerate actually at the
time there weren't
very many women in the menswear business
and i went to work for the president
of the international division of the
menswear side of the company and
that really set me up on the course of
then staying in the menswear industry
for
over 15 years
i worked for ron chareskin jeffrey banks
then morona sport then i had the
opportunity to work for willie smith who
was an incredible
designer in the 80s who really believed
in
culture driving fashion and change
then worked for tommy hilfiger and then
ralph lauren
so how does your style develop working
for that series of people
so i think there's a couple of things
that have defined
my leadership style one is
i pretty much have wholly worked for
entrepreneurs
my entire career so
i've always had this entrepreneur
curiosity
passion around what it is i do
i'd say the second thing that defined a
lot of my leadership
style is i never believed that i needed
to bifurcate
my work life and my personal life
you know it's hard enough being one
mindy nevertheless trying to be
two and that was a little difficult you
know
in starting out even with a family and
being a mom and being a wife and working
but i always felt it made me more
accessible and have more humanity
and if you look at the pandemic and what
we've been through
people literally look up to leaders
who are willing to show themselves
and show empathy and
really show care across
all areas of the business financial
social and human
so one of my favorite things about you
and and and full disclosure
you know you and i are friends that i've
become friendly with both you
and your husband neil and and one of the
fun things that i got to do is talk to
neil a little bit about you so
i'm gonna have you watch something uh if
we can that that he told me
when i talked to him and i asked him
just to tell a story
that he felt captured your relationship
you guys have been married for 33.
you're nervous
no i think i i think you're gonna i
think you're gonna get a kick out of
this okay
we have a phenomenal daughter you met
her i believe
but you know she was your ish you know
14 15 year old and she was having
friends for a uh
sleepover and they were going to go
party you know new york city kids and
they go out
and they're all dressed to the nines one
of them comes home at about 8
30 and says i'm a little tired goes to
sleep and the rest of them show up about
an hour later and it was a sort of a
you know one of those moments and i
looked at my wife and said
can i help and her answer was no that
was probably 9 30 and she's finished
dealing with the issue at about 12 30 or
one
and and she comes and she's sort of
steaming
not so much at them but me and she says
some help you and i said
i don't work for you
and she looked back and said that's
right you would have been fired a long
time ago
i so remember that moment
you remember that i so remember that
and you know the funny part is we are
such
opposite human beings you know neil is a
mathematical physicist
at his core and some of that is black
and white
and you know i'm kind of opposite on the
spectrum so some of the funniest times
in our marriage
has kind of been laughing at the
differences
and and the one thing he didn't mention
the second i said yes
you don't work for me because i would
fire you we got hysterical laughing
yes and there has to be those moments of
tension that can turn into humor
you know that's that's what life is
right
like so many high-powered executives the
pandemic has kept mindy in one place
her home in the hudson valley north of
new york city it's a living testament to
her and neil's eclectic taste
along with a sense of whimsy she gave me
a virtual tour
so every room has its own different
personality
ah there you see him in the sun room oh
there he is hard at work
one of my favorites is
this room and this is part
library part dining room part art
installation
if i go around there's maryland
salvador dali marie antoinette
mick jagger einstein
frida kahlo audrey hepburn
and abraham lincoln
this is where i've been working since
march and you can see the eclectic
nature of
our reading and our books
this is actually robert the bruce and it
actually
opens
[Music]
and this is tartan house
it's been kind of a labor of love that
we've been up here which
you know to a degree it's a gift i never
would have spent as much time up here so
it's
it's been a lot of fun with the family
[Music]
all the while grossman has been
continuing a corporate transformation at
ww
one zoom call at a time the turnaround
hasn't been easy
or universally hailed especially by
shareholders who were wildly
enthusiastic
and then skeptical hey sally you were
still on that diet grossman and her team
had the delicate task of radically
reshaping a brand long associated simply
with dropping pounds
so i got through the party without
eating one bite of cake
to an era that has a much more holistic
approach to living one's best life
when the company hired grossman in 2018
the brand felt antiquated
and candidly out of touch clearly
weight watchers was a brand that had
been around forever
but if we were going to go into the
future we couldn't just be defined by
weight
i know people laughed at me a little
when i said we are going to ban the use
of before and after pictures forever
because health is a journey and
what i want at this point in my life and
what i
need is very different than what my
daughter who's a young mom needs
and today we don't tell you what you
have to weigh
what we say is what is healthy mean to
you
what are your goals and how do we help
you get there and that's not about a
number
on a scale among that sort of
reassessment how do we think about
our wellness because that
has all changed as well and and i wonder
how you think about it
you know it's interesting when you know
i joined the company
a little over three years ago we were
talking about
wellness and talking about the wellness
economy and the trillions of dollars
but no one in the world was getting
healthier and this pandemic has
only heightened that reality and
wellness has absolutely gone
from being a luxury to a necessity
especially if you look at covid and
the leading indicators and cause of
death around obesity and diabetes
i'd say the second thing that is
critical today
the trust factor around brands
has really heightened there is so much
misinformation
out there and if you can be that trusted
brand
and that partner for people that is
a significant opportunity and then
lastly if you could build it all around
the power of community
and bring people together around common
values
today that's more important than ever
grossman's tenure has not been without
controversy after firing
thousands of workers over zoom calls
during the pandemic
she and her team faced a raft of public
criticism they literally just said
i'm going to be reading from a script
you will not be able to speak the women
say it was all over
after just three minutes i had never
been fired before
so here i am 66 years old grossman
defended the decision as part of the
company's inevitable
digital slimming down we have made the
decision
to accelerate our efforts particularly
in digital and virtual
and unfortunately that had us make the
very difficult decision
that affected a number of employees
around the world
this past year was brutal for so many
businesses
you had to lay people off you faced
criticism for
the way that you did that like how does
that feel in the moment
and how do you sort of keep that north
star look
no one you know enjoys
right when people are coming at you for
something you've done
but the way i think about it is any
decision
that i've ever had to make that
affects anyone in any way
is a very carefully humane
decision now we came into the year with
the greatest momentum
the company's ever had and then the
world shifted
and we had to make the decision to close
our offices
and pause every one of our physical
workshops but we trained 14 000
coaches and guides and simultaneously
launched all those workshops virtually
in 12
different markets so the learnings from
that have now created
a whole new opportunity for us
grossman had a not-so-secret weapon to
deploy when it came to ww
oprah the woman who taught the world how
to feel
and has publicly struggled with her own
weight took a stake in weight watchers
in 2015
and became an ambassador and board
member hanging out with oprah all the
time
is probably most people's wildest dream
uh but also i would think at least but
this is me talking
i'd be a little intimidated how do you
like
manage a relationship with oprah and
sort of get the best
that you can out of yourself and and out
of oprah
one thing you have to know about oprah
you have to know about oprah she is so
diligent and specific about what
she will do and what she won't do
and it's the things that you say no to
right that actually really define you so
anything she does
is purposeful and
what i realized is that we both saw the
same opportunity
for this brand that had actually been
transforming lives
for so many years but now in a new
generation
we could be so much more
as the world started to realize the
extent of the covet 19 pandemic
grossman was on the road with oprah
firing up arena-sized crowds with their
shared vision of a new kind of health
and wellness
powered of course by ww are there some
days
where you look at yourself and you go
damn
even kovid couldn't stop the momentum
with ww
offices and its network of retail
locations shuttered as the world quickly
went remote
hey everybody grossman's team created a
four-week free
virtual tour of sorts starting in may
when we had to make that
pivot when the pandemic happened yes
within a few weeks we launched
a virtual tour led by oprah
and we made it available for free
to everyone globally i see you all look
very good
up top but no telling what you got on
the bottom
and uh at some point we all gonna have
to
put real pants on again and we're gonna
hope they fit
that's what i'm doing right so speaking
of board members mindy you know one of
the other people i was able to catch up
with was julie rice who i know has
become a friend of yours
of late but that wasn't always the case
and so
i actually asked her how
you guys met originally so i want you to
check this out ah julie's so great i
can't wait to
okay back uh when i was opening my
second soul cycle on east 83rd street i
was a new entrepreneur
and two mutual friends of mindy's called
and said that they were going to be
bringing mindy grossman to a class
somebody like mindy was a full-blown
celebrity i couldn't think of a
celebrity that i would rather have come
right at soulcycle than mindy i mean i
remember prepping the front desk with
flowers and making sure that i got there
early to make a sort of a perfect little
you know swag bag for her to take home
and i met her and she came and she took
the class and
the whole time she was in class i was
just thinking to myself gosh i hope she
likes this
i just remember her being so tuned in to
what we were trying to create there
and when a good girlfriend of mine sent
me a text and she said you know mindy
grossman is going to run weight watchers
you know that is
something that you should try to get in
on and so honestly i stalked her
i sent her a note we hadn't spoken in
years i had no idea if she would
remember me
and sure enough she got back to me
within the next you know hour or so and
she said i'd love to head you want to
have a cup of coffee in the next week or
so
um that's sort of how our friendship
began and then ultimately i wound up
joining the board and
i learned sitting next to her i learn
about being a better leader
i learn that the idea of not innovating
is scarier sometimes than shaking the
whole thing up
i would just say that mindy is really
brave and really
innovative oh
well it sounds like she wasn't gonna
stop until you guys were like
well connected she she i would not get
in her way
the one thing she and i have in common
is
an insatiable sense of curiosity and
when we see
something or you know want to do
something
we'll put ourselves out there and you
know i've kind of been known to stalk
people
too if i'm if i really want to
learn more or be able to have
a conversation you know to go how did
you do that
or why did you do that if you're more
curious
you're going to be more diverse in your
thinking in general
and so surrounding myself with people
like julie
and you know other members of our board
is one of the most valuable things that
i or
we could do you know so mindy it's
interesting
to to interview and i'll say this as
like a
middle-aged white man asking you asking
you this
you know we we strive so much to talk
about you know it's not a male ceo or a
female ceo
it's just a ceo and yet you have been a
trailblazer by all accounts
uh i know a lot of women look up to you
so
what advice are you giving to women who
were who are coming up
so i would say a couple of things number
one
is i believe the reason i've been
successful
is i have focused my career on making
other
people successful because if i do that
they will be more successful the
business will be more successful and
ultimately i will be more successful
the second thing is self-awareness is
your greatest
superpower you need to truly understand
your behavior and its impact on others
and know everything about yourself
whether it's the good the bad and the
ugly
and know how you need to show up
to motivate people the third thing
is progress not perfection i think
too many women have felt that they don't
put themselves out there because they
have to wait to be perfect
and you know i think i make people like
you know open up their eyes when i say i
don't believe
i've truly been 100 ready for any job
i've ever taken but i've always
defined myself as a transformer
with the ability to create positive
change around business
positive change around impact
you